and the idea for me is that we need a
history then of trying to understand how
people have tried to respond to
planetary threats to see whether there
may be lessons learned that would guide
us going forward and so in doing that I
can't think of anyone I'd rather hear
from then then Roger pilkey when we're
talking specifically about climate
change because I've learned a tremendous
amount I still think of myself as
someone having a lot to learn but but
what I do know much of it I learned from
from reading Roger pilkey and also just
from from trying to apply some of the
principles that I think he's defended
very effectively just basic principles
of scientific integrity and being honest
about uncertainty he's somebody where
the more you read in his work the more
you realize that he's impossible to
categorize even in this incredibly
polarized field he really doesn't you
know fit in it ways to make some people
feel uncomfortable but I feel in ways
that make for incredibly valuable
contributions and provoking us to think
harder and think harder about especially
about our assumptions and are about
about our values so as a historian I
really appreciate his values in this
work I could tell you about some of the
many things that he's done i'll do that
briefly because you have it already in
your brochure many of you already know
that he's on the faculty at the
university of colorado and he has been
for more than 10 years now before then
he was a scientist at the National
Center for Atmospheric Research he's a
recipient of multiple prizes and
honorary degrees he's also the author of
some excellent books that you should buy
if you haven't already and more recently
that would include the honest broker
making sense of science and policy and
politics and especially the climate fix
what scientists and politicians won't
tell you about global warming it's a
fantastic book I know that not just
because I've read it but also because I
know how hard it was to get a hold of it
it's pretty much sold out almost every
bookstore in Manhattan so I congratulate
Roger on on writing a book like that
maybe someday I'll write a book like
that too that will will sell out as well
so so let me just turn things
over to him and thank you again Roger
for joining us there you are thank you
we just had a nice discussion with the
students in the program and I guess this
will be a continuation of that
discussion hope you'll jump in and
interrupt I appreciate the nice
introduction but Matt didn't say is that
if the publisher only prints like a
hundred and seventy five copies they
sell out really so the title of my talk
is climate policy for a high-energy
planet and I'll explain that and I have
an ambitious goal with this talk I
really don't want to convince you of
anything other than there are some
really powerful tools out there that you
can use to get your arms around what is
a very messy difficult issue I will tell
you what I how I apply those tools but
as I'll tell you you will have to do the
hard work to understand this issue and
hopefully this talk will open some doors
to understanding it so the current
context we could talk a long time about
how we got to where we are you're
probably all familiar with the fact
President Obama presented finally a
climate policy agenda to speech a couple
weeks ago at Georgetown and then the
days afterwards Secretary of Energy
Ernie Moniz emphasize how important coal
was going to be in the future US energy
mix I'm kind of a mixed message there
there's a lot of attention being focused
on the economy such that climate change
is dropped pretty far down if it ever
was very high japan in germany two
countries that had very strong pledges
germany still does Japan is abandoned
there's to reduce emissions have seen
their emissions increased sharply in
Japan's case they're burning a lot of
oil post-fukushima Germany has said
they're going to phase out nuclear
they're on their way to doing that and
they're building coal at the fastest
rate in 20 years in that country just
last week Angela Merkel told Europe that
they were that she was not going to sign
on to new controls on automobile
emissions
because of mercedes-benz and BMW
international negotiations are at a
standstill there's a expectation that
there will be a decision made in 2015
about future negotiations China and
India meanwhile keep growing and
emitting so how do we understand this
context and what I'm going to argue is
that there's a a common pattern
underlying pretty much the entire global
geopolitics of the climate change issue
to let you know where I stand if you
google my name you might find my father
is a prominent scientist but if you find
me you'll find people calling me names
and you know skeptic denier Marxist
leftists climate hoax believer so I
thought it might be useful as I start
out just to tell you where I stand on
issues I've been studying the climate
issue for 20 years hard to believe and
I'm a strong advocate for both
mitigation thats related to energy
policy co2 and adaptation which is doing
better with respect to climate
variability and change there's no doubt
in my mind that the continuing increase
in the atmospheric concentration of
carbon dioxide in particular could pose
large risks and I would point you to the
working group one of the IPCC if you
want to get a good handle on the science
stabilizing concentrations that's a term
of art a technical term which I'll
explain precisely momentarily at low
levels can't succeed if we underestimate
the scale of the challenge one of the
first things that you learn when you go
to school to learn about policy is that
if you miss define the problem you're
unlikely to come up with effective
interventions action on mitigation will
not result from the elimination of all
scientific uncertainty I find that the
debate the continuing debate over the
science of climate change is a
distraction it's harmful to the science
and it's something that we really are
must move beyond if we're going to make
progress on this issue the politics of
the issue are indeed poisonous it has
become a very partisan issue it is
almost to the level of being a partisan
litmus test in the United States the
focus on extreme weather is a
distraction and often adventures in
the deeply scientifically unsound and
where I'm going to wind up today is to
argue to you that technological
innovation makes political action easier
not the other way around hopefully that
will make sense by the end all right so
why should you believe what I say and
the answer is I mean would you buy a
used car from that guy you shouldn't
believe what I say I would ask that you
do the math yourself i'm going to
present in this presentation a lot of
graphs a lot of data all of it is
replicable by you in an afternoon take a
little time my students doing this in
the graduate seminars i teach and i
don't think they really understand the
issues until they do it themselves so so
please carry with yourself a healthy
dose of skepticism about the claims i'll
make today and then if you're interested
try it out yourself and see what answer
you get all right let's start with the
mainstream approach to climate change
the mainstream approach is what's been
called the targets and timetables
approach there's some pretty graphs up
there and the way that it works is
scientists have come up in this this
generic phrase scientists have said that
there's a two degree above
pre-industrial threshold over which
climate change becomes dangerous human
caused climate change becomes dangerous
the two-degree threshold is associated
with 450 parts per million concentration
of carbon dioxide you can see on this
graph this is the 450 line and then
there's this dash line to throw a bone
to the 350 people there may even be some
280 people out there who are
pre-industrial but the point there is is
that we can identify a threshold you can
then run climate models to give you a
wide range of possible futures and come
up with a probability of exceeding that
threshold for different levels of
emissions so bill mckibben who you're
going to hear from later this summer in
this program has a widely read article
in
stone called do the math perhaps you'll
read it and I recommend it to you
because it outlines this approach you
work backwards from that two degree
threshold and that tells you what your
allowable emissions are in order to have
a fifty percent or more probability of
staying below two degree that total
amount of emissions that you're allowed
then tells us what we globally can emit
until in this case 2050 on this graph
you can then allocate those emissions
according to population GDP historical
responsibility pick your pick your
criteria and come up with some very
colorful curves that say something about
how emissions have to go down then you
can take those curves and turn them into
targets and timetables for emissions
reductions so you may have heard eighty
percent by 2050 Europe likes a literal
numbers twenty percent by twenty twenty
thirty percent by thirty 30 that sort of
thing but you can come up with those
judges that's where that comes from and
the idea is that the science dictates
how we have to act in the pace at which
we have to act now I would call this the
equivalent of scientific performance art
it's very authoritative looking it's a
good story sounds good but really no one
no money I mean me you we don't know
what's behind these numbers we don't
know exactly what they mean someone
smart put it together but we really
don't know what's underneath the hood
what I'm going to offer to you as an
alternative framing or construction of
the issue it's perfectly consistent with
this view but it's I would say more
empowering from the standpoint of
thinking about policy action the reality
is that governments around the world do
not look at colorful curves with the
amount of emissions you're allowed and
use that as the basis for constraining
their economic growth supporting
technology it just doesn't the world
just doesn't work that way let me say
from the outside outset that the energy
issue is far more than just climate
change climate change is more than co2
I'm going to emphasize co2 it's quite
possible that we could it's difficult to
believe is this is we could deal with
the co2 issue and then still have a
major human influence on the climate
system set of issues remaining to deal
with but energy is obviously more than
just climate change and from the outset
I want to make it explicit that there
are something like 1.5 billion people
worldwide who have no access to
electricity none I'll talk a little bit
about what that term means access to
electricity something like 800 million
people cook their food with with dung
with wood with trash energy is the
foundation of wealth prosperity around
the world so it's going to be very
difficult as the students I met with we
just talked about it's very difficult to
separate those out even though we've
tried to in the climate issue all right
so let's start with the the simple
mathematics of stabilizing carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere so if you know
how a bathtub works then you understand
the challenge of stabilizing carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere stabilizing
carbon dioxide atmosphere is the same
thing as stopping the increase of water
in a bathtub when you have the spigot
turned on the water coming in is
equivalent to the emissions of
greenhouse gases of carbon dioxide we're
putting in the atmosphere primarily from
the burning of coal natural gas and
petroleum there's some good news it may
be bad news also is that this little
hole in the bottom of the bathtub that's
letting some of a water out that's
equivalent to the land surface which
takes up some of the carbon dioxide that
we admit plants get greener they grow
faster the soil takes up some carbon
dioxide but a lot of the carbon dioxide
is absorbed by the oceans you may say
well that sounds good but it's bad news
for the oceans because it changes the
chemistry of the oceans which may have
negative consequences the only way the
water in the bathtub stops increasing
is if the amount coming in equals the
amount going out that little hole in the
bottom if you don't want to use the
ocean as a sponge to take up excess
carbon dioxide the amount going in our
missions have to essentially go down to
zero that's how you stop the water
increasing in the tub and however long
it takes us to turn that spigot off its
dictates how high that water will be now
sometimes scientists and advocates find
themselves in arguments over how high is
our bathtub is it at 450 parts per
million there's even a group 350.org
who's named themselves after a height of
the bathtub I will tell you I think that
that debate is absolutely irrelevant the
reason for that is that the policies we
would adopt to stabilize at 450 at 350f
500 at 750 are identical if we can
figure out how to stabilize at 450 or
550 we can probably figure out how to
stabilize it at 350 and so that's
somewhat of a distraction in the larger
debate now let's look at the water
coming in the spigot this is a graph
that comes from the global carbon
project the black dots I'm not sure this
black dots are actual emissions and the
colourful curves and the gray shaded
area shows the projections that were
made in two thousand one thing to notice
is that the black dot the actual
emissions are at the upper end of those
projections that were just made a decade
ago here's an update to that and one of
the most interesting things about this
graph is that if you start in 1990 where
this graph begins and go to 2000 you see
kind of a linear increase in carbon
dioxide emissions one percent a year
then you see kind of things shut up the
growth rate has been about three percent
three-point-one percent it tripled so
during the time with which apparently
we've expressed the most concern about
accumulating carbon dioxide our
mission rate has tripled so the water is
coming in the bathtub faster so that's
bad news
another way to look at this and I'll
return to this at the end is the
proportion of global energy that we
consume that comes from carbon free
sources if you want to shut off that
spigot the water coming into the bathtub
then for however much energy we consume
ninety percent or more necessarily is
going to have to come from carbon free
sources what this graph shows is the
proportion of the global energy mix that
comes from carbon free sources from
nineteen sixty five to twenty twelve
last year and it's pretty fascinating
because it starts out at about six
percent then there's this rapid increase
it doubles in just about two decades to
more than thirteen percent largely
because nuclear power expanded by a
factor of 100 that's carbon free with a
big punch and Bend hydropower dams
increased by a factor of 25 over that
same time period so much to my surprise
1999 was the peak year for carbon-free
energy worldwide something like 13.3
percent and now we're down to about 13%
so over the last almost 20 years the
world has not seen a growth in the
proportion of energy that we get from
carbon free sources so you may have read
news stories and promotional things
about the rapid growth of solar and wind
and it's true there has been rapid
growth but they still make up less than
one percent of the total global energy
supply I'll return to this at the end
what this graph shows if you can see it
there's some green at the bottom this is
the annual increment in new energy
coming online each year from 1966
through 2012 and the green part shows
the portion that is carbon free and what
you see is that fossil fuels are not not
only winning their routing they are they
are dominating
the growth still all right so let's say
you are interested in stabilizing carbon
dioxide how might we think about that
challenge the good news from an
analytical standpoint is that we can
think about the tools we have in the
policy tool box to deal with carbon
dioxide comprehensively and and I'd say
this and I sometimes I joke about it but
there's one sentence you can use that
encapsulates the entire set of tools in
the toolbox people engage in economic
activity that uses energy from carbon
emitting generation so dazzle your
friends win bets impress your family so
we take that sentence we turn it in two
variables population GDP economic
activity per capita energy intensity of
the economy I'll explain that in a
second and carbon intensity of energy so
its population gdp per capita total
energy consumed / GDP carbon or carbon
dioxide emissions / total energy that we
consider this is called the kaya
identity it's named after the Japanese
scientists who first proposed it it was
first proposed as a tool to help climate
modelers if you want to drive a climate
model you want to run it one of the
things you have to know about the future
is what emissions will be and if you
want to know what emissions are going to
be yet to know something about how many
people are going to be on the planet
size of the economy how they use energy
and how they produce energy it's good
news the unit's cancel when you get
carbon equals carbon that's the kaya
identity you can google it I can read
about it it's the basis for a lot of
literature it turns out the kaya
identity is also an extremely powerful
tool of policy analysis and that's the
use that I'm going to put it to so the
kaya identity tells us all of the tools
in the toolbox if you want to reduce
emissions to the level of stabilizing it
so with respect to each one of these
four factors there's a lever so each one
of these things
can be used to reduce emissions so less
people all else equal equals less
emissions a smaller economy all else
equal equals less emissions increasing
efficiency so that means doing the same
or more with less energy that reduces
emissions increasing efficiency is a
different thing than not doing anything
at all so if you're lying in bed one day
and you say you know I don't want to go
to work today I'm going to reduce my
carbon footprint no that doesn't work
think being lazy doesn't work you have
to do the same or more with less energy
and then the final category there is
reducing carbon intensity of our energy
sources so generating energy with less
emissions so if you switch from coal to
natural gas you become more carbon
efficient about forty to fifty percent
more carbon efficient if you switch from
coal to nuclear or wind or solar and get
a much bigger punch but these are all
the tools that are in the toolbox all of
the policy instruments that you may be
discussing or have heard of
cap-and-trade a carbon tax contraction
and convergence all of them are focused
on modulating these levers and the good
news from an analytical standpoint is
that there's nothing else there's no
other levers that you can use out that
this is comprehensive you may wish there
was some rabbit you can pull out of a
hat because the good news is also the
bad news this is all you have so I'm
going to make things a little simpler
for our discussion I'm going to combine
population and per capita wealth and
just call that GDP so that's economic
activity and I'm going to combine the
technologies of energy consumption with
the technologies of energy production so
the technologies of consumption our
PowerPoint projectors and lights and
cars and airplanes the technologies of
energy production our power plants and
solar panels and so on that's technology
and so we have two factors emissions
result from gdp x technology now let me
at this point introduce what I call in
my book the iron law of climate policy
some of those things you put in a book
and then after the book comes out and
people start talking about it you
realize well then maybe that's that that
actually grabbed people because that's
probably the one concept from the
climate fix that people talk to most
about and I'm going to illustrate it
this way this is a graph that's an
opinion poll that was taken in the
summer of two thousand nine it was taken
right after the House of Representatives
voted on the cap and trade and if you
remember the House passed the
legislation didn't get through the
Senate and at the time the pollsters
asked people the American public would
you support a generic climate bill if
the annual cost per household was X so
the first number was eighty dollars a
year and it turns out that at eighty
dollars per year more than fifty percent
of Americans even with the partisan
split on the issue supported the idea of
a climate though when it got to ten
times that amount this is at 770 the
number of people expressing support got
up to less than ten percent so this
downward sloping curve between
inexpensive policy having high support
an expensive policy having low support I
would argue it holds everywhere maybe
the numbers are a little bit different
maybe the proportions are different and
i would say it holds in this room too so
we'll just do a little experiment how
many of you would be willing and able to
pay a dollar a year support climate
policy raise your hand side
all right how many of you would be
willing and able to spend a million
dollars a year I'm kind of policy hoping
somebody raised their hand I'll say come
talk to me about supporting our research
so that's a little facetious but you
pick your own numbers the reality is
that this downward sloping curves is
just an essential fact of policy if
there's one area where there's a global
consensus across political views across
religious views demographic it's this
idea that the economic growth is
important everyone loves economic growth
so this led me to conclude that people
around the world are willing to pay some
price for climate policies but this
willingness has its limits it has its
limits in New York and Europe even in
Boulder where I'm from these limits mean
they're reducing gdp or noticeably
reducing GDP growth are just not option
an option as a strategy of emissions
reduction it's just not going to happen
so I I call this a boundary condition
for policy design climate policies must
not cost too much but even better they
should support economic growth because
that's the direction of the prevailing
winds so at the same time people are
talking about climate there's been this
wonderful success story or is it a
success story I put a question mark
there that the world is on track to meet
the millennium development goal of
having an amount of people who are in
poverty which is defined according to a
arbitrary threshold of a dollar of
dollar 25 a day for what you can see is
the sharp decline and the Brookings
Institution writes the new estimates of
global poverty presented in this brief
serve as a reminder just how powerful
high growth can be in freeing people
from poverty now I want you to think
about the idea of freeing people from
poverty in the context of the kaya
identity that's illustrated with this
graph which i think is just fascinating
what it shows this is from the UN as one
of the
background papers that was prepared as
part of the Millennium Development Goal
process but it shows an estimate of
global global income distribution for 33
points in time so the dark curve the one
on the Left that's 1970 the dashed curve
that's 2000 and then this light gray or
blue I don't know if you can see it on
the right my laser pointers going away
that's 2015 and there's some normalized
dollars a hundred dollars on the left
hundred thousand on the right where the
bell curve gets to the edges but what
you see is this progression from your
left to your right that's reflecting the
fact the world is getting wealthier the
income distribution is moving from the
left to the right so I would ask you
what direction do you think policymakers
and the public want to see this curve
move going forward I'd argue they want
to see it continue moving to the right
now if you think it's possible that
there could be organized policy to move
to the left then you're going to take
issue with the iron law of climate
policy but if you think that people are
going to try to become wealthier and
improve their material standing then you
basically except the iron law of climate
policy some some notes just some some
pointers eighty percent of the world
lives on less than ten dollars per day
so that's less than four thousand
dollars a year that's that's ninety
percent of what's called the developing
world question is what do you think
they're material aspirations are so so
eighty percent of the world that's like
five and a half billion people you think
they want to live on more than four
thousand dollars a year or less another
note typical salary of an academic
they're not Bill Gates but they're doing
fine in this global income distribution
when I present this and I go to college
towns there's always academics who want
to say we have too much growth they get
into their Volvo and they drive back to
their nice house it's very easy to say
we have too much growth when you
at the right hand side of the income
curve so I am going to leave behind at
this point GDP as a as a lever for
reducing emissions there's wonderful
discussions we could have about income
inequality distribution of wealth around
the world I simply don't see it as a
viable lever for stabilizing that water
in the bathtub so let's go back to the
kaya identity and see where that leaves
us all right we have emissions equals
gdp x technology and I've just told you
that you're not going to be able to use
gdp in any meaningful way to reduce
emissions corollary to this is that any
discussion of emissions reductions
without talking about GDP is incomplete
because they're so closely tied together
so I'm going to use the magic of
mathematics and put gdp over with
emissions isolate technology and I'm
going to argue that a reduction in this
ratio of emissions to GDP is an
indication at least with respect to
carbon that we're making progress so we
want emissions to go down and we want
GDP to go up and if that happens that
ratio goes down that's progress with
respect to technology and so I'm going
to show some numbers with respect to
this ratio now I'm going to define this
reduction in that ratio as
decarbonisation of the economy so
decarbonisation of the economy is
reflected in a decrease in the ratio of
carbon dioxide emissions to GDP and two
thousand six which is the numbers that I
used in the climate fix and I'd be happy
to talk about more recent numbers the
world emitted 29 gigatonnes of carbon
dioxide and the global economy was about
forty seven trillion dollars that
equates 2.62 tons of carbon dioxide per
thousand dollars of gdp now it's not
enough to say we want to see that ratio
reduce because mathematically try it
yourself but trust me for a second it's
possible for this ratio to go down and
emissions to go up forever this is why a
stabilization target actually matters it
doesn't matter if it's 350 or 450 or 550
you'll see
consequences are pretty much the same
but if you want to achieve stabilization
you have to actually have some level of
this ratio where it reaches you know and
i'll show you what that is so
historically this is from 1982 2006 the
global economy was decarbonizing that's
good news we're not talking about doing
something different we're talking about
accelerating a process that was already
in place now if you have good eyes might
be able to see can't see the laser
pointer at the end there that gets a
little Wiggly flattens out in fact the
decarbonisation curve has turned around
since 2006 but the world has been
decarbonizing for much of the past 100
years there's that point six two tons of
co2 per thousand dollars of gdp so we
can ask a policy question that's enabled
by the kaya identity so what if we want
this emissions to reduce by eighty
percent by 2050 I just picked that as a
number it's often bandied about it's
it's it's used by 350.org you see the
small island nations have used that
number if you like seventy percent
that's fine fifty percent by 2050 that's
okay too ninety-five percent none of the
conclusions i'll present to you our are
depending upon the selection of that
number so you know now from the kaya
identity that we have to specify a rate
of gdp growth in order to talk about
what this decarbonisation curve will be
in the future so i'll give you five and
i'll give you an anchor so this starts
at that point 62 and if we have to
reduce emissions eighty percent by 2050
for five different rates of gdp growth
so one percent to five percent and give
you an anchor 1982 2006 was
three-point-five percent all of them are
below point one so we're at Point 62 so
if I say we have to go from point six
22.1 you might say oh that's only point
five point five that's a small number
easy no problem so what I'd like to do
next is give you a
sense of what is that in terms of a
policy ask what does that mean more
intuitively than these abstract
decarbonisation numbers and the reason I
say that the stabilization target
doesn't matter and the emissions the
amount doesn't matter they're they're
all below point one and if you want to
go below point2 that's fine but the
challenge of getting them low is
essentially the same from a policy
standpoint it's insensitive to your
target because the challenge is so large
so I took the middle range I stapled it
on to that historical curve that's what
it looks like that's what we would have
to do for a three percent gdp growth
rate and i'm going to start i'm going to
drill down now i'm going to talk about
the united kingdom united kingdom in
2008 past the the most rigorous
legislation of any country in the world
for the reduction of carbon dioxide
emissions so it provides a wonderful
test of efforts to try to decarbonize
through policy here's the
decarbonisation curve for the united
kingdom so this is tons of carbon
dioxide per thousand dollars of gdp and
like most large industrialized economies
you see this steady downward slope from
1982 2006 the UK is actually a very
carbon efficient economy there are about
fifty percent more carbon efficient than
the global average there at point four
two tons of co2 per thousand dollars of
GDP one reason for that is they have
offshored a lot of their manufacturing
which was very energy and carbon
intensive these graphs which come from
the Financial Times show manufacturing
output is the top curve and
manufacturing employment on the bottom
and all you need to see is the slope the
slopes shows that manufacturing went
from about thirty two percent 1972 about
twelve percent in 2007
so the legislation that was passed by
the UK parliament in december two
thousand eight mandated that the UK
reduce its overall emissions by thirty
four percent 1990 levels by 2022 so now
that we have a kaya identity as our tool
we can say well what does that mean for
decarbonisation so here's that curve
starts at that point for two when i
first did this analysis i assume that
the economy of the UK was going to grow
turns out that the economy of the UK has
shrunk fairly dramatically since then
which gives the illusion of progress
with respect to carbon when there's not
any progress i'll show you some updated
data shortly David Cameron would be
doing back flips of joy at two percent
annual gdp growth but here's five
numbers from one percent of three
percent and in your mind you can scale
it up to zero percent if you want the
point here is all of these numbers are
about point 15 2.2 by 2022 what does
that mean what does that mean
intuitively so i'm going to use france
as a way to answer that question france
has the lowest ratio carbon dioxide to
gdp of any big economy who knows why is
that shut it out nuclear power there at
point through there less than half the
global average I have a bunch of
countries here you can recognize them by
their flags of germany japan united
states china britain India Australia
Canada Italy pick your favorite no one
is lower than France but the point I
want to make it this grad here's the UK
point for two if they're going to get
below point 25 they have to go
through point three where Francis on
their way to that lower value so what
does it mean in practical terms for the
UK to be as carbon efficient as France
it's a question we can answer
empirically first let's take a look at
the French decarbonisation curve so this
is nineteen eighty four to two thousand
six and it turns out that France
actually went from point 4 to 20 point
three over a period of 20 years it is
possible a large economy can decarbonize
from point for to 2.3 the question is
can the UK do it faster can you do it by
a policy so what would it take so here's
those decarbonisation curves implied by
the UK climate change act i put this red
dot which is france where they were in
2006 if we bring that across to where it
crosses the axis and then drop it down
that tells us by when the UK would have
to be as carbon efficient as france so
as to be on on path to hitting its
emissions reduction goals if you squid I
tried to make that red dot really big so
that it hit 2015 doesn't quite get the
2015 and so I have fun with my UK
colleagues and I have this title can the
UK become France by 2015 but that's
what's implied to be on on pace to hit
that decarbonisation target what does
that mean in terms of energy so what
I've done is I've scaled the magnitude
of the challenge of being as carbon
efficient as France in terms of
carbon-free energy i'm going to use
nuclear power plants this is the
dungeness be nuclear power plant on the
coast of kent in england it's a one
gigawatt nuclear power plant sometimes
when i show this picture some people see
nuclear and they the mind goes blank and
they don't see anything for the rest of
the talk this is just a measuring stick
if you like solar panels or offshore
wind or whatever you can use it's like
being measured in pounds or kilograms
just because you're measured in
kilograms as when you weigh less so I'm
using a nuclear power just to give you a
sense of the scale so the question is
how many dungeon is be nuclear power
plants worth of carbon free energy would
have to be deployed by 2015 for the UK
to be on pace to hit that 22 target
here's the answer the answer is 40
nuclear power plants worth of carbon
free energy now this tells you the
magnitude of the test the United Kingdom
government has something called the
Climate Change Committee which has put
together a big thick report that has
taken this magnitude and spread it out
all over the economy you could put
insulation in buildings you could have
electric cars you could build onshore
wind offshore wind that doesn't make a
task easier or small say it make it
makes it harder but raise your hand if
you think that the deployment of 40
nuclear power plants worth of carbon
free energy in the UK the next 18 months
is going to happen probably not
so I gave this in a talk in 2008 and it
was a fairly public talk big audience
some people from the Climate Change
Committee were in attendance it was
written up by the BBC and at the time
Colin challen who was the chairman of
the all-party parliamentary climate
change group said this the talkies
analysis raises questions which I do not
think I've been factored into the
thinking behind the climate change the
task of cutting emissions is already
staggering huge and as we have seen well
beyond our current political capacity to
deliver then he said something which I
think gives us a little window into why
it is we're not making more progress and
I'll return to this momentarily he says
he throws a prime example of ducking the
responsibility it's hard to see any
tough choices being made in the current
climate so hold on to that Keith Pro
thought for a second now when this was
presented publicly a leading economist
terry barker for the IPCC
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change the big dog in the climate change
issue he was quoted in that same news
store and he said professor Pell keys
intervention was rejected by economists
terry barker now one of the good things
about economics and emissions reductions
policy is that time allows us to
evaluate arguments we don't have to lean
on academics arguing over esoteric
things 2011 The Guardian reported this
Britain will miss government carbon
targets by increasingly wide margins
over the next 20 years unless it
introduces radical policy measures
argues Cambridge econometrics a private
company owned by a charity and shared by
the cambridge university academic terry
barker so excellent so we have agreement
the UK is not going to hit its emissions
reductions targets so how's the UK doing
since it passes climate change a what
this graph shows a little bit
complicated but the two black bars at
the bottom show rates of decarbonisation
at the bottom is two thousand to two
thousand eight so that's right up until
when the climate change act was passed
the next black bar up shows the rate of
decarbonisation from 2009 to 2012
so over the four years since the climate
change act was passed just over one
percent the red bars show what would be
implied by 1% two percent and three
percent gdp growth more than three more
than four more than five percent so
actually the UK has moved backwards in
the four years since the climate change
act was passed so my analysis is out of
date it's not 40 by 2015 it's probably
more so let me return to the heathrow
debate Heathrow Airport how people have
been there it's it's not the most
efficient airport it operates at like a
hundred and two percent of capacity and
the United Kingdom seems to want to
remain at the centre of international
travel they want London to be a major
city and they need more capacity so
starting really about six years ago and
really continuing to today there's been
a debate about building a third runway
at Heathrow and what you can see there
are some Greenpeace protesters on the
back of a British Airways jet the sign
says climate emergency no third run away
so they're obviously trying to make
friends with travellers inside the plane
you may see just today and yesterday
someone was caught climbing the shard in
London new big building same kind of a
stunt and I'm going to illustrate while
as well-meaning I have some fun with it
but as well-meaning as these folks are
insincere as they are these sorts of
strategies are probably not helpful to
extend it to a u.s. context putting a
circle around the White House and
holding hands to protest keystone XL
would be in the same sort of category so
here's the broader context Wow they're
debating a third runway at heathrow
China is building 100 new airports each
heathrow size and larger by 2020
this graph shows on the left is China's
emissions in 2007 6511 megatons or 6.5
gigatonnes of carbon dioxide the middle
bar shows where it was in 2012 and it
shows the annual increment so each one
of these added bars that's the 2008
level 2009-2010 to 11 2012 increase my
fifty percent by 2012 for comparison the
u.s. is at about five thousand or so so
trying to exceeds the US what I did in
the bar on the right is to show the
entire emissions for various countries
in 2012 so since 2007 China has added
the emissions of the United Kingdom
South Africa Australia Brazil and
Germany right now China is adding a UK
worth of emissions about every 9 or 10
months so really the the third runway at
heathrow is where we want to put our
time on environmental campaigning it may
be cathartic but it's probably not the
sort of thing that's going to affect
those levers of the caia identity now
what I'm presenting is not new this is
from ken caldera Marty Hoffert and
colleagues is in science ten years ago
and they wrote to achieve stabilization
at a 2 degree warming we would need to
install 900 plus or minus 500 megawatts
of carbon emissions free power
generating capacity each day over the
next 50 years this is roughly the
equivalent of a large carbon emissions
free power plant becoming functional
somewhere in the world every day so a
nuclear power plant worth of carbon free
energy coming online every day from now
to 2050 and I'm gonna make things worse
in a second so that's something like
10,000 plus or minus nuclear power
plants worth of carbon free energy
that's the scale of the challenge
now let me return to where I started
with this idea of the billions of people
who lack energy access one of the the
dirty secrets I guess of climate policy
is that the success stories we tell
ourselves before 50 stabilization
scenarios the 350 stabilization
scenarios for the most part keep the
vast majority of these 1.5 billion
people in the dark the reason for that
is if you account for them having energy
access at any reasonable level it blows
up your carbon budgets we just don't
know how to do that so our integrated
assessment models are models of energy
access in the future have what I would
call very pitiful levels of energy
access and if you say energy access
maybe that makes the issue go away so
let me illustrate what this shows our
number of numbers let's start with the
red bar that's the 2010 actual per
capita electricity consumption globally
three thousand kilowatt hours over a
year of consumption that's the global
average including all those people with
no energy access the black bar
immediately above that that's the 2035
comes from the US energy information
agency projects about fifty percent more
consumption per capita clover about
4,500 that's equivalent to the next bar
up that's about the average of Bulgaria
today now let's compare that to some
other countries so the next bar up
that's Germany there about seven
thousand kilowatt hours with a very
efficient highly efficient country
wonderful transportation system
wonderful use of energy and then a hot
the high example that's the United
States that's us that's more than 13,000
now the definition of energy access what
does it mean to have energy access
that's on the bottom that's the IEA
International Energy Agency I don't want
to pick on them because it's a very
common number it's about two percent of
what we enjoy in the United States so
when I talk to my students and I say
energy access most of them are playing
with the cell phone or computer they go
to their house they have
air-conditioning like oh yeah I know
what energy access is I got it no that's
not energy access energy access is four
hours a day of a 40 watt light bulb
that's it to me that seems like a very
low almost a pitiful amount it helps us
square our carbon budgets looking to the
future but it probably doesn't address
issues of equity and the actual real
world demands of people for true energy
access around the world so let's take a
look what just just as a thought
experiment so on the bottom again
there's that EIA actual so this is the
total energy consumption 500 quads don't
worry about what a quad is it's about 15
nuclear power plants worth 500 quads of
energy consumption in 2010 worldwide and
you see the next the black bar the next
one up is about fifty percent more by
2035 it's very common ExxonMobil has it
i EA has it World Bank has it and then
let's let's turn those numbers from the
Bulgaria equivalent German equivalent us
equivalent into what that would imply in
terms of global demand for energy and
all of a sudden you have a doubling of
today's energy at rippling or even four
to five times more so if you would like
hypothetically speaking the entire world
to live like Germans so very efficient
very high standard of living then and
you want to decarbonize the economy
same time you don't need one nuclear
power plant worth of carbons free energy
every day till 2050 you need three so
think about that for a second the
magnitude of the challenge of providing
energy access true energy access around
the world is larger than the climate
change challenge all right the climate
change challenge is one nuclear power
plant per day to 2050 and the energy
access challenge is two to three times
so when I make the argument that energy
access provides a more compelling reason
globally for energy innovation that's
the numbers that are behind it sure
climate change motivates a lot of people
in the rich world but if you have energy
access at two percent of what Americans
enjoy do you think that's a motivating
factor for the vast majority of people
around the world i would suggest maybe
not all right so let's wrap up here so
we can talk so what I'm suggesting here
based on these numbers is that we really
need to change the narrative of the
climate debate a lot of the debate in
the wealthy parts of the world focus on
statements like we use too much energy
fossil fuels are too cheap we need to
make them more expensive and I would
flip that around and say actually we
need vastly more energy sure we should
become more efficient in its use it'll
go further but we're not going to use
less and part of the problem is that
fossil fuels are too expensive we need
cheaper cleaner more accessible energy
not more expensive energy
so how fast can decarbonisation of the
global economy actually occur I think
the starting point for good policy
analysis here is to openly admit nobody
knows we're in uncharted territory I can
tell you that right now and for most of
the past decade the world is reek
arbonne izing what that means if you go
back to the kaya identity that the
carbon intensity of energy is going up
and the energy intensity of gdp
surprisingly is also going up so
historically before the last decade is
about a one to two percent rate of
decarbonisation in developed countries I
had graduate students one year go
through all the historical data for
decarbonisation said find the country
with the fastest rate of decarbonisation
for five years for ten years for 20
years for five years the fastest rate of
decarbonisation we could find was 4.4%
per year it was Japan when they got rid
of their aluminum industry layoff
shorted big energy hog and a GDP sink at
the same time 4.4% for the u.s. to hit
seventeen percent that President Obama
has committed to by 2020 wow so it's
seventy percent of 2005 so while
maintaining modest economic growth one
percent two percent requires rates of
decarbonisation greater than five
percent for you we're not going to hit
that target that's a prediction that I'm
going to make the economic slowdown the
brief burst of shale replacing coal has
given us some illusion that were
actually reducing emissions and we have
in the United States but it's temporary
it's small change in the price of
natural gas and that's going to reverse
really fast so this is this is the graph
I showed you before this is the
proportion of global energy that comes
from carbon free sources what you see
six
nineteen sixty-five up to thirteen
percent 1999 and pretty much a state the
green arrow shows where we need to go so
forget about all this nonsense about
targets and timetables for emissions
reduction it's it's it's a sideshow it's
it's a well it's the path to insanity
number one but it's also unlikely to
bear fruit from a policy standpoint that
the question we ought to be asking is
how are we going to generate ninety
percent plus of our energy from carbon
free sources at the same time we double
triple quadruple global energy supply i
would say that puts a different spin on
the magnitude of the challenge and the
sort of things we ought to be doing
rather than talking about limits and
constraints on emissions reduction we
ought to be talking about the
opportunity afforded by cleaner more
accessible energy all right so i'm going
to finish up two more slides so
hopefully you've got in the sense i'm
happy to discuss it further that the
policy logic of targets and timetables
is exactly backwards i'll say little bit
more about that in a second climate
policy should not as an outcome keep
poor people poor and it shouldn't keep
them in the dark morally I think that is
a non-negotiable outcome cap-and-trade
can't succeed we have ample success
success ample experience with that both
from a policy standpoint and trying to
implement it in a political standpoint
and trying to tighten it carbon tax
similarly can't do the job I would ask
you how do we do with other sorts of
wicked problems that we don't we start
out by saying we don't know the answer
and I'll just just give you one
advancing human lifespans how was it the
world was able to advance the average
human lifespan by several decades 20-30
years over a century do we get together
and have a global treaty that specified
targets and timetables for life span
improvement and I make a joke and you
know there's some economists who tell me
it's an identical book cap-and-trade but
why not put a price on death and have
tradable death permits to great
incentives for innovation in medicine
it would work according to economic
theory people laugh at it it's the same
logic yeah we were able to make progress
so I'll go back to this graph imagine
this is the human lifespan graph it had
a curve something like that how are we
able to do that all right so oh and this
is from Jessie awesome Bell this is a
picture of the world at night from space
kind of a present picture you maybe you
can make out North America and you're up
there it's probably all you can make out
they also say well what does the world
look like if everybody lives like North
Americans it's in Europeans that's this
world so that's the world we're headed
for like it or not we can go there in
dirty energy uncoordinated unthinking
fashion or we can do it smart I'd argue
for the smart I'm here's how you can
find me I welcome your feedback your
criticism your comments a lot of papers
related this talk you can download and I
run a blog that's currently dormant for
the summer while I'm doing fun things
like visiting you guys but it should be
spun back up by September so thank you
for your attention i preciate so Roger
there the title of the book is what
scientists and politicians or the
subtitle of what scientists and
politicians won't tell you about global
warming but they're there for those of
you haven't read it you know there are
other things you know in the book and
some things that you didn't have time to
talk about today and also in your blog
as well and as provocative as you been
this evening you're even in some ways
even more provocative and some of the
chapters that follow so for instance
about how it is in what some scientists
anyway in politicians especially tell us
about climate change that they're
oftentimes no miss representing not just
these kinds of facts but but others as
well about about climate science and
about climate modelling so I was
wondering if you could just talk a
little bit about that just give us a
flavor you know for
some of the very direct arguments you
make about for instance some of the work
that you especially well known for about
hurricanes for instance and how that
figures in climate politics yeah let me
um I mean there's a lot I know that's
that's a lot we could talk about here
but yeah but if you go back to one of
that first graphs that I showed with the
integrated assessment model and you know
the Keeling curve sort of approach early
on it became part of the debate that
there had to be consensus reached on
views on the science of climate change
as a precondition for political action
to occur there was this idea that that
skepticism which has morphed into
denialism was simply not acceptable and
we've embarked on a path and I think
it's abated somewhat partly the skeptics
have run out of steam and partly the
scientists have grown frustrated and
moved on to other things but there's
really been a ongoing debate involving
advocates high-level scientist
politicians to try to scrub the world
clean of skepticism and there's a couple
things to say about that one is that
that reflects a belief that there's some
sort of causal link between degree of
belief in science and certain political
or policy outcomes in the book i provide
some data that's taken from the
political science literature had nothing
to do with climate in which the the
scholars asked what was the level of
public opinion when major action took
place on various issues and it turns out
just broke this way for the 36 cases
they looked at that in 18 of the 36
cases public opinion was in the
direction that action took place and in
18 other cases it was in the opposite
direction the fact that something like
seventy percent plus or minus of the
American public thinks climate change is
real and has a human component has
remained more or less dead
over 20 to 25 years the fact that
something like sixty five percent of
Americans will say they support action
on climate change places the issue right
into a sweet spot where there's nothing
unique or special about public opinion
on climate change that would lead you to
think that we cannot take action on this
issue what you do see is that all of the
efforts to enforce or motivate a unified
view of the issue have turned the issue
into a political litmus test if you are
a good Republican you better be against
that climate issue if you are a good
Democrat you better be helping to get
rid of the world of climate deniers and
it's actually it's fair to say we know
what comes first on that issue now the
politics or the science and continued
efforts to try to win that political
battle over the science I've just led to
more polarization and I think there's a
you know a great exact on policy
outcomes I think as I've shown because
there has been very little policy effect
what it does do though is it has served
to politicize the scientific community
has undercut the legitimacy that leading
scientists have in political debates if
you take a look at polling data over the
last 15 years one trend that is
consistent across Republicans Democrats
and independents in varying degrees of
course is the belief that the scientific
community exaggerated seeeeee claims on
climate change and that's partly a
reflection of the idea that this has
just become a politicized issue you see
this you mean raise the issue of
hurricanes the science of hurricanes you
know
looking back in time there are
projections we can have more intense
hurricanes going forward but looking
back in time the science of Hurricane it
is not rocket science counting
hurricanes is pretty straightforward you
don't you don't miss them when Sandy
comes through New York you see that it's
here so counting up the number of
hurricanes that have made landfall
historically is pretty straightforward
science and the reality is there has not
been an increase in those storms might
there be in the future very possibly so
in fact right now we're in the longest
stretch of no category three four and
five hurricanes hitting the United
States of the last 100 plus years so
when President Obama stands up at
Georgetown to talk about climate change
and it's just a throwaway line I know
and he says you know we're having more
droughts floods storms and then it when
he did his radio address he actually
said hurricanes and not a single climate
scientist the bloggers the public faces
say well he actually got this point
wrong not one of them says that it's
assigned to me that there's something
not quite right in the scientific
community because you can imagine if
george w bush stood up in 2003 and said
the world is not warming you can imagine
that the scientific community would have
gone nuts to correct that error I think
the scientific community gains
legitimacy by being fair-minded about
equally correcting you know miss
statements by public officials even if
they support the cause so I think that
the disaster issue is one there's a long
story that I relate in the book and it's
gotten longer since the book was written
about how the IPCC has had very
difficult times with a disaster issue
they finally did get it right in 2012
but the scientific community has become
wrapped up in the politics and I think
that hurts the science and I don't think
it's particularly to the policy issues
associated with energy people who care
about energy
and discuss a debated energy actually
they don't much care about climate
science or what the scientists say to
begin with I think it's a much more at
home issue for the scientific community
so uh let me um open the floor I see
there a few of us ready to engage thank
you for the talk I'm wondering you
talked a little bit about in your book
about the kind of the role of scientists
and how in many ways science is kind of
getting this tendency to exaggerate
things or not do the things that you
believe they should do and I'm just
wondering in order to deal with this
climate change issue it seems like
almost people often say that the science
is already done there the scientists
concluded the science we know what the
science is it's going to happen so I'm
wondering what do you think the role the
scientists should be from here on fourth
if in fact you assume that this science
is already known conclusively this
climate change issue is really an issue
worth dealing with yeah that's a great
question and you know I Tim it's really
important to say I mean and I I do give
the scientist a hard time I think
deservedly so but but the scientific
community really over almost a half
century has done a great job of bringing
to the public's attention a challenge a
problem that the public would not
otherwise be aware of and it's well
established that humans affect the
climate system and that effect could be
very negative going forward and we have
the scientific community to thank for
bringing that to our attention what that
does is it opens up a space of
possibility where the scientific
community got into trouble wasn't then
trying to use the science to close down
that space its cap and trade its carbon
trading no skeptics what we need help
with now is in the creation of new
policy options this became really
evident after the copenhagen climate
conference in 2009 world leaders were
there der Spiegel the German newspaper
has a fantastic really eye-opening audio
recording of the world leaders Merkel
Sarkozy Obama sitting on a table
actually talking to each other about
this issue the long story short is that
Copenhagen was a crash it was a disaster
and you would think when a policy fails
what we normally would do is say what
else you got that one didn't work let's
try something else and because the
climate issue had become so narrow so
quickly the answer was I got nothing
let's wait until 2015 and then try it
again and what I would love to see is
much more attention on this is kind of
inside baseball but working group three
issues so economics issues and even
broadening it be on climate change so
you can read my talk as an effort to try
to expand the issue let's put energy
access at the center try that for a
while see if that gives us more
motivation for energy innovation will it
work I have no idea is it better than
cap-and-trade yeah I'm very convinced
about that but I would love to see the
scientific community in wholesale
support of more perspectives broader
discussion I'll decide another example
there's a German scientist who provided
his taxonomy of deniers and at one level
there are the climate science deniers
you don't believe there's a problem the
second level is the climate impact
deniers these are the people who don't
believe that the impacts are severe and
at the third level are the climate
policy deniers there against the
framework convention on climate change
now once you equate belief in science
with belief in a single policy I think
something's gone very wrong and how we
deal with sticky issues without a lot of
possibility thank you
hi so I like the fact that you brought
up energy access to the forefront it's
very important one of the millennial
goes so my question is more than human
aspect if energy access was afforded to
everyone on the planet if it was
renewable if it was carbon free egg be
done in a day would there be anyone to
stop it would it be adopted freely by a
people so here's the the big challenge
is that it would be nice if we had the
technologies at scale that were
carbon-free that were technologically
ready economically affordable and
politically acceptable we have a
technology that provides lots of energy
is reasonably safe that it's sharply
contested nuclear power right the world
could set on a path of saying we're
going to replace every coal plant
worldwide with the nuclear power plants
would it cost money yeah it would cost
money a lot of climate advocates would
probably say it's cheaper though given
the costs and benefits the externalities
and so on so what do you do with nuclear
proliferation issues what do you do with
the Middle East what do you do with
nuclear waste what do you do with
technology transfer we could build large
dams Africa has a lot of places where
you could still build very large dams
for hydropower you could build solar
farms that take a big footprint one of
the most contested issues in Australia
and in great britain right now is the
siting of wind farms people don't want
them so the energy issues they very
rapidly involve much more than just
climate considerations and at every
energy technology does constituency for
and against so my reading of that is
that the politics are such that there
isn't a global consensus on either
energy access or climate change
Germany is right now deciding they would
rather have co2 emissions in nuclear
power is that acceptable in a democracy
I don't know so it becomes really
difficult really fast hmm thank you yeah
my-my question kind of follows up on
that and that um you know you alluded
earlier in our life discussion to like
the hungry world and stuff like that and
how you know these other kinds of you
know non grandiose things can motivate
important action but like if the energy
access problem is happening in the
poorest parts of the world like what's
the strategic concern that's going to
make rich countries do something about
it particularly when I mean you know I
mean the other part of that book says
that part of the solution is the
strategic thing but also the way you
frame the problem you know like was
global hunger actually solved no not
really right right um and I mean you
know it's like we've made a lot of
expenses with you know health and things
like that but like malaria is unsolved
because it's not of interest to
pharmaceutical companies so well I mean
what do you see being that thing for
energy access in the dark parts of the
world now China and India yeah I mean
it's a great question and I have some
numbers I just roam down from memory i
don't know if they're correct i tweeted
them around from i was at a meeting
earlier this week on energy access so
take pakistan pakistan has and I think
these are right you can check me but
they're approximately correct seven
thousand megawatts have installed
electricity capacity for 90 million
people seven thousand for 90 million
Virginia the state of Virginia has forty
thousand megawatts 47 million people so
I would say do you think energy access
has anything to do with the geopolitical
situation that Pakistan finds itself in
and relations between Pakistan and the
United States and so on i would say that
there are a lot of related issues they
may not be linear and they may not be
directly causal issues for which
energy access plays a key role the
previous questioner mentioned the
Millennium Development Goals it turns
out that energy access was not a
millennium development goal I wasn't
involved in process I don't know why I
think it will be going forward I think
the next decade is the UN is targeted to
be the International decade of
sustainable energy for all but it has
not been at the center of discussions
like climate change has been like other
issues have been and I would say if you
know for the students here think about
it what how much time do you spend
debating worrying about discussing
policy options for energy access versus
climate change why is it what is it
about the issue that has led to one
versus the other and I think that energy
access as I you know provided the
numbers provides a really compelling
justification for innovation policy for
spending money on innovation policy but
one that the majority of the world can
get behind in a way that they are very
wary about climate policy thank you very
much for joining us here I just have a
quick question in terms of the emphasis
on energy axis so you know your time out
putting a lot of investments into
renewable energy research more so than
focusing on mitigation or mitigation by
changing people's behaviors yet the
statistics that you put up there seemed
a little bit unrealistic in terms of
what we have to achieve and the progress
that we have currently and especially
seem like some of the biggest sleeps
like Japan and the UK for instance in
energy intensity efficiency was due to
outsourcing so pretty much you're like
pushing these energy-intensive
industries to other countries that have
worse infrastructure that are more
inefficient that have less access to
renewable energy and given this process
seems that this that focusing on that is
not going to reach the levels that we
need especially given that solar and
wind
our kind of really cost and efficient
right now without severe subsidies
nuclear power is highly contested and
hydroelectric power is very limited in
terms of work can be placed so my
question would be how are you supposed
to in just and emphasizing this how are
you supposed to meet the goals that have
been set forward for reaching carbon
neutrality like how more some policies
that we can look to more specifically
yeah right so i'll give you let me just
give you two answers one of them is to
repeat to do the math yourself when you
have a chance the uncomfortable reality
is if you want to stabilize carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere from today's
level 90 percent or more of our energy
consumption has to come from carbon free
sources it could be cold with CCS it
could be nuclear could be solar could be
wind pickier it mathematically it has to
be that way now you might say well I
want efficiency to play a big role and I
want to reduce the amount of energy we
consume okay let's say you reduce
today's energy can some of that 500
quads to 250 fifty percent reduction
nobody thinks it's possible let's just
say that we posited what have you done
now only eighty percent of your energy
has to come from carbon free sources so
you don't really change the nature of
the task we have to get the vast
majority of our energy consumption from
carbon free sources this is something
that I think we need to have very
crystal clear is that all of the
instruments that we talked about cap and
trade carbon tax the purpose of all of
these instruments is to motivate
innovation and energy systems so that we
get to that ninety percent and so the
debate is really about the means to
achieving this larger goal what I'm
trying to do is put that larger goal
right in front of you because if if we
can't do that then we will have failed
when you talk about what policies do we
do I would go back to human lifespans
agricultural production and people are
too wrapped up and how we finish the job
how do we get to ninety percent I have
no clue and now you know really I don't
care what I care about is how we get
from thirteen percent where we're at now
to fifteen percent and from fifteen
percent to twenty percent until we make
those first little steps then it's it's
irrelevant to talk about that and the
world's going to look different when
we're going from fifty percent to
fifty-five percent so this is the the
comprehensiveness and hubris associated
with solving the climate crisis in one
big bite is one of the factors that have
kept us at thirteen percent for 20 years
how are we going to feed the world of 10
billion people who want to eat like
Americans in 2050 I have no idea and
most agricultural experts don't either
but they know how we improve
agricultural productivity and we go from
a world of 7.5 billion to a world of
seven point eight billion and so I think
part of effective policy design is a
recognition of where we're just
fundamentally ignorant and just in being
okay with saying we don't know how we're
going to finish the job so that's that's
what I would say about policy let's
let's forget about the 2050 what are we
going to do to 2020 and until we can
move that dial on that thirteen percent
then we're just spinning our wheels
thank you
hi um I'm curious as to where the United
States's and your analysis because I saw
some you know interesting analysis of
the UK and a lot of talk about China but
China is actually the fastest
decarbonizing country in the world right
now and we're definitely not and on a
per capita basis we're still emitting
way more than China is and in terms of
the energy access argument I think it
really comes in here because so agarwal
in terrain back in 1991 made the
argument about luxury emissions versus
survival emissions the energy access
argument is about survival emissions
it's about you know the basic
necessities of life and how many people
in the world are denied that and the
counter balance of that is how many
people in the world have way way past
the necessities of life and the
incredible wastefulness of the way that
this society is constructed and it seems
to me that there's a very strong
argument to be made about the united
states that was not in your presentation
and i'm wondering why um it's in the
book i also have australia and japan and
i start with the UK just because they
were out of the gates first i can do a
similar analysis of the united states i
have the number in terms of required
nuclear power plants the US just in case
you're curious is about 13.5 percent of
our energy consumption comes from carbon
free sources so a little bit above the
global average it's incorrect to say
that china is decarbonizing faster than
the u.s. actually china is the primary
reason why the world has recognized and
in terms of intensity not in terms yet
intensity so so according to the 2012
figures they decarbonize dat
three-point-five percent in terms of per
dollar of gdp yeah we can we can discuss
the data be happy to share that just put
it up had a piece up about this
yesterday china is actually their energy
intensity is turned around
and so has their carbon intensity so
look the emissions in the UK in Germany
what else did the five countries that I
had up there are about equivalent to the
United States the the source of growth
worldwide and emissions is going to be
from countries that today are relatively
poor we could take the United States off
the map pretend it doesn't exist and it
really doesn't change the mathematics of
the carbon challenge I will take issue
with this distinction survival emissions
and luxury emissions you know in kind of
a smart aleck way I explained that
climate campaigners would like to make
better higher-quality poor people but
still poor people they kick around the
soccer ball that allows them to plug in
the light at night they have their four
hours of light bulb but they don't have
dishwashers they don't have washing
machines they don't have iPads I mean we
you start with the light bulb and then
you get to the dishwasher and the
washing machines only the reason that
that energy access is not a millennium
development goal is because they were
set in two thousand and clean water was
considered a far more important goal
than energy access there you know it's
one of many problems yeah you know I
don't know why energy axis was a lot of
discussion and debate about why it
wasn't on there it's not that it wasn't
proposed but that's the simple reality
right now is that twenty percent of the
world's population uses eighty percent
of the energy and you could say well
let's cut them back by half by
two-thirds you still have the other
eighty percent and just do that ask you
to do the math how how high are their
energy commands going to go are they
going to go to a thousand kilowatt hours
per year 2000 3000 4000 to Bulgaria
levels the reality is the world is going
to consume massive amounts of new energy
irrespective of whether
Americans or Europeans or Australians or
Japanese have luxury emissions I think
the idea that that you're going to
address the emissions problem by asking
some people to cut back fundamentally
misses the nature the problem I'm all
for more equity globally and I'm all for
talking about whether we consume too
much but I'm also for being clear that
that discussion is not the same
discussion as how do we stabilize carbon
dioxide and I'd be happy to see you work
out the math of emissions that show me
differently I think we have time for one
more question Danya sure yeah I'm you
know I like your presentation you give a
lot there's a lot you you pick a lot of
bones kind of as climate scientists and
the kind of climate policy elite so far
and I take a lot of your points and I
think they're they're pretty persuasive
but it seems like you've kind of left
one group out in terms of why things
aren't happening and that's basically
very wealthy capitalist executives and
other rich people in the US so we know
that you know less than one percent of
Americans give the fewer than one
percent of Americans give donations of
more than two hundred dollars in
elections um you know when you look at
like the u.s. cap to bait you have
substantial number of met people you
know executives in place like the
Chamber of Commerce we're closing ranks
with the oil industry even though you
could easily make an argument they have
a stand to benefit from different
policies but clearly on the issue of
government regulation they're opposed
and you point out correctly that there's
more than enough public opinion support
for climate policy but we also know that
the if you look at the relationship
between public opinion and policies that
are passed I'll Larry bartels at
Princeton did this work you know that
overwhelmingly it's the opinion of the
top third of income even higher which
relates to policy and there's like a
zero percent correlation between the
bottom third and policies that are
passed so when you're saying so I you
know I I think you're right that energy
access is a compelling issue but you
can't on the one hand say that energy
access is a more compelling issue than
climate change and at the same time hold
I think correctly that climate change is
already kind of compelling enough I mean
the question is what is it going to take
to remove the opposition to you know
regulatory policies and too taxing
policies that has been largely help
held up by very wealthy people on people
who are paying for things like a tea
party so you know what where where is
this like where is this group and where
is this political forest in your story
and why have you left it out of the kind
of morality tale that you have yeah all
right so there's a few things here one
is that when cap-and-trade failed in the
US President Obama had a
filibuster-proof majority in the Senate
he had an overwhelming majority in the
house and he was a Democratic president
and it was blocked by 10 mostly
Midwestern senators who have interest in
coal so if the criteria for action is we
need to get even more left-leaning
Democrats in the office I think it's
just a recipe for failure it sounds
great it's part of seeing it rally
certain troops but a trance in energy
transition is we're going to require
support for a generation there has never
been a time when the presidency the
Senate and the house was controlled by a
single wing of a single party for
anything approaching that amount of time
right that's the argument that I'm
making is that people are the people
like you to scotch Bowl have made is
that you you have biscay moderate
Republicans who can't make the kind of
votes that I'm sure you would suggest
that they would make because of pressure
from funders and from grassroots groups
that are financed by it you know there's
two ways to look at that and there's one
thing that you can one way to look at
that is to say there's something
inherently wrong with this political
party this group with their view and we
have to either change their their views
or get them out of office there's
another way to look at it and to say I
need to design a policy architecture
that appeals broadly to people of
differing political perspectives there
are aspects of what i have written in my
book which some Republicans find
appealing interestingly go online that
is used to impeach my views i would
think you know where's the award from
the environmental
groups saying you finally have gotten
Republicans to talk about climate change
so I think we have to figure out what's
what's the carton what's the horse here
I would say you know I I don't I I'm of
the view and I will apologize for this
I'm not of the view that rich
industrialists in oil companies that are
association with tea party United States
matter all that much on this issue if
you look at the global energy economy it
is state-owned companies in the Middle
East in China that are completely
dominating the global energy
infrastructure if you change the
composition of the US Congress you vote
in Joe Rome its president pick your I
wouldn't vote for him I I might vote for
me would be fun you you pick your your
composition and then say well does that
change things globally you know I think
we give ourselves too much credit and
our ability to have fight our inter seen
partisan battles let me just say I just
to correct one thing I don't see energy
access as a trade off with climate
change what I am trying to present to be
very clear is if we do the energy access
thing right then climate gets to pay
back on back on the back of it I can
think of if I am going to go you say i'm
going to pick human being x at random on
planet earth you need to make an
argument to them for why we need energy
innovation given the distribution an
equity around the world yeah they're
from Boulder where I live maybe climate
change is what I lead with but in
general it's probably we're going to
need a lot more energy and we don't know
how to get there and oh yeah you're
going to deal with this thing that's
going to affect your children and
grandchildren so I I think that though
most people in developing world support
climate policy I mean the way more
people there is us is something like
70th in the world in terms of the number
of American people who believe that
humans cause climate change which seems
like an okay proxy for you know gomber
you could say that but you know India
with you know the head of the IPCC is an
Indian rajendra pachauri who has said
very explicitly India will be any he's a
scientist and he's persuading the play
debate this is India will be happy to
talk about emissions reductions after
2025 when where's riches you so you know
the the the uncomfortable reality of the
international climate debate is that it
has caused a deep divide between rich
and poor countries that's a lot of
suspicion and a lot of resentment at how
climate policy has been framed by a lot
of folks in poor countries but I agree
i'm just wondering like just to insist
on the final point point of my question
is like it's easy to have it it's yours
climate policy people and scientists
take a lot of hits and your work but
other people who it seems and like every
you know in terms of actual everyday
politics have probably done more to
prevent progress or not in the story and
i can take UK so you could say that take
the coast out of the picture it's not
going to solve every problem and i agree
but but i wonder if they are kind of
getting off lightly and the in the
basically cast of you know heroes and
villains yeah okay well let me just
answer i mean if this was about you know
adding up scores I'd agree with you
entirely but look at it as I'm
practicing what I preach I don't think
those people matter I think the
legitimacy of the climate science
community matters and I think people who
at least formally say they really care
about climate policy matter and it's
much more important for me that they put
forward solid policy architectures and
maintain the integrity of science and
you know advance I do not care what the
heritage Institute does I don't they can
do they can put up billboards they can
you know I do not care because I think
they're largely irrelevant so yeah if
you want me to say mean things about
them let's go to dinner how a few drinks
and I'll let loose but in terms of the
policy debate they there nothing burger
I mean it's that's how I feel all right
all right x okay thank you thank you so
much Roger all right so so please come
back next week and the rest of the
summer we're going to have a number of
other lectures in the weeks ahead and I
hope you'll come back and join us soon
as well but tonight thank you again
Roger pilkey thank you thank you
you